[Aplausos]
hace un año la rabia de miles de
colombianos se tomó las calles de las
principales ciudades del país en el
mayor estallido social de la historia
reciente que se prolongó durante más de
dos meses el detonante la fallida
reforma tributaria del entonces ministro
de hacienda alberto carrasquilla que
luego fue derogada y él rechazó las
políticas del gobierno de iván duque en
medio de la crisis social y económica
debido a la pandemia que dejó más de 21
millones de colombianos en la pobreza
pero las manifestaciones
antigubernamentales pronto se tornaron
sangrientas
debido a la brutal represión de la
fuerza pública y la estigmatización de
las autoridades de la protesta social en
su mayoría pacíficas las organizaciones
de derechos humanos locales recopilaron
más de 80 muertos al menos 40 homicidios
presuntamente a manos de la policía y el
esmad que arremetieron con dureza contra
los jóvenes en las calles que exigían
una reforma policial inmediata hubo al
menos 35 casos de violencia sexual más
de 100 jóvenes perdieron la vista por
los ataques directos de la fuerza
pública además de cientos de
desaparecidos y medio centenar de
montajes judiciales de miembros de las
denominadas primeras líneas las
alarmantes cifras coparon la atención de
los organismos internacionales la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos viajó
al país andino desde donde emitió más de
40 recomendaciones al estado
365 días después los organismos
denuncian que no hay justicia ni
reparación para las víctimas y que
ningún informado ha sido procesado por
los hechos ocurridos durante el
estallido hoy se cumplió un año desde
que perdí la vista a manos de la
violencia policial en colombia no hay
justicia ni reparación contrario a eso
tuve que salir del país por amenazas
como me dueles colombia
a poco menos de un mes de los comicios
presidenciales en el país más letal para
los defensores de derechos humanos con
52 asesinatos de líderes sociales en el
primer trimestre del año queda por ver
si la rabia que detonó en las calles se
refleja en las urnas